democrats ignore their own coveted rules
while calling for everybody else to lock
down
lynnwood and sydney pell call for
republicans to boycott the georgia
senate races for some insane reason
and barack obama touches off a battle on
the left by suggesting that the slogan
defund the police is actually a bad idea
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
protect your data from prying eyes at
expressvpn.com
ben obviously the big news of the day
remains this giant coveted spike that
the country
is in the middle of it looked like it
might have been waning a little bit
before thanksgiving it looked like we
were on the other side of a slight curve
but then it turned out that that was not
in fact the case what we are looking at
today is the highest number of diagnoses
of covid that we have ever had in the
country we have over 200
000 diagnoses of the cases yesterday and
hospitalizations are at an all-time high
as well
so our deaths the deaths and the
hospitalizations obviously trail covert
diagnosed cases by a couple of weeks
which means things are going to get
worse for at least another couple of
weeks
not better and given the fact that we
are just coming off of thanksgiving
there are a lot of people traveling for
thanksgiving there are probably more
infections
now again my view on covet and covet
rules has been pretty simple for a long
time
be cautious and be careful but be
reasonable with yourself if you are
young and you are healthy your risk
factors are not the same
as if you are older or if you are infirm
if you have serious underlying
conditions you should be staying away
from public places in which there are a
lot of people particularly in enclosed
spaces
if you're young and you're healthy you
should be staying away from people who
are particularly
vulnerable right my standard here has
been pretty consistent
unfortunately the standards for
everybody else particularly the
democrats who are setting the standards
are not
completely consistent okay so here's the
actual numbers that we have right now as
of this hour
there are over 3 100 coven 19 deaths
reported on wednesday that's an all-time
high for the pandemic this is cnn
reporting
healthcare systems are struggling to
support the weight of a worsening impact
well i mean truthfully what you're
talking about even in major metro areas
where you've seen a significant
uptick in cases is they are worried that
the health care system might be
overwhelmed by maybe the end of december
by about christmas time um in florida
there's really no worry about that in
texas there's not been a lot of worry
about the health care system being
overwhelmed again even in la where
they've seen a significant
spike uh they're not really worried
about it being overwhelmed as of today
the more recent death toll is an
increase of about 20 from the previous
record of 2600
set on april 15th of course back in
march and april the middle of the
country was not affected
nearly at all by the pandemic it really
was a coastal
phenomenon it was really mostly a new
york new jersey connecticut
massachusetts phenomenon but obviously
it is now a nationwide phenomenon
including spikes
in previously hard-hit places new york
has seen a wave of covid
as well over the course of the pandemic
we are currently at nearly 275
000 people in the united states who have
died and at least 14 million people have
been infected according to data from
johns hopkins
the truth is that it's probably closer
to seven or eight times that number
because again in the early days of the
pandemic testing was just not very good
and there are a ton of people who are
walking around asymptomatic
the search has pushed records that set
one day to be broken the next the spike
in covet deaths came on the same day the
number of people hospitalized broke a
hundred thousand
according to the coveted tracking
project the number of hospitalizations
had been steadily growing over the
course of the last month that is because
people don't go into the hospital and
come out the next day they linger there
for a week even before they are released
now the good news is
that if those numbers had been 100 000
back in march and april
many of the a huge number of those
people would have died right now
some of those people will die but the
number of people who are hospitalized
and end up dying in the hospital
much much lower down about 80 from where
it was back in march and april thanks to
therapeutics and the fact that we now
know how to treat this thing a little
bit better and the fact a lot of the
people who are ending up in the hospital
are in fact younger and healthier it's a
different cross-section of the american
community according to the american
ambulance association the 911 emergency
call system is quote at a breaking point
without additional relief it seems
likely to break even as we enter the
third surge of the virus
in the midwest and the west the cdc said
wednesday things aren't likely to look
better for hospitals anytime soon dr
robert redfield said the reality is
december january february
are going to be really rough times i
actually believe they're going to be the
most difficult time in public history
health of the nation
largely because of the stress that's
going to be put on our health care
system
and well this has led to calls for
massive lockdowns particularly in highly
populated areas eric garcetti who is the
idiot mayor of los angeles actually
issued
a massive lockdown order yesterday and
by the way lockdowns are happening
all across the world i mean that is
worthy of known right germany has
extended
its lockdown for example there are
places all over
all over the world that are extending
their lockdowns however eric garcetti
has now said that he is going to tell
everybody to basically stay home
here was mayor eric garcetti from los
angeles telling everybody to stay home
except if you're in the film production
business in which case go ahead and go
to work
my message couldn't be simpler it's time
to hunker down
it's time to cancel everything and if it
isn't
essential don't do it don't meet up with
others outside your household
don't host a gathering don't attend a
gathering
and following our targeted safer at home
order
if you're able to stay home stay home
okay well this actually supersedes his
lockdown order from june and it mirrors
the la county rules that are stricter
even than the la city rules
garcetti's order according to
fortune.com prohibits public
and private gatherings of people from
more than one household
right all gatherings of people from more
than one household so
you want to get together with your
brothers and sisters no good
and states that all businesses in the
city that require people to work on
location must stop operations
i mean there are certain exceptions to
this if your grocery store you can still
operate apparently film production is
still able to go on because you know
that's an essential service walking
driving travel on public transport
bikes motorcycles and scooters are
prohibited other than for those
undertaking essential activities okay
that's insane
i mean that's perfectly crazy the the
idea that you are not allowed to walk
around
in your neighborhood for exercise or
that you're not allowed to get out in
your car
with your kids and just take a drive
somewhere like to a public park and then
drive back home
that's crazy that's crazy and then
people wonder
on the left why it is that people are
not obeying the lockdowns why this has
not been particularly effective
because when you promulgate insane
regulations nobody is going to keep them
there are several exemptions including
for faith-based outdoor services and the
homeless
others that can continue to operate
include supermarkets grocery stores
healthcare operations
that does not cover gyms in similar
facilities
the city's safety protocols on social
distancing follow those developed
by la county of course and l.a county of
course also happens to be a place where
they banned outdoor dining
the other day so these regulations make
no sense
okay even if you were to claim i think
rightly that indoor dining is more
dangerous based on the data than outdoor
dining to ban
walking and driving to places
other than those for undertaking
essential activities is nuts and what in
the hell is he taught
you're not allowed to bike around the
neighborhood you're gonna be spitting on
people while you bike
this is crazy and then people wonder why
people got coveted fatigue and just
decided you know what screw it
i'm relatively young and relatively
healthy we're done here
and i'll tell you what else undercuts
this the fact that everybody in public
life including these democrats knows
that these regulations
are not going to be obeyed so actually
in la they're now trying to hit you with
a misdemeanor fine
if you do any of these things and
they're actually going to try and
enforce this thing
good luck so you've got a city that
cannot stop rioting for weeks on end in
the middle of the summer and in which
eric garcetti went down to the protest
with no mask to hang out with people
okay and
yet they're going to enforce social
distancing to the point where if i'm
walking around in my neighborhood
if i'm walking a dog then all of a
sudden a cop is going to show up and
write me a ticket
you can't even rouse the 65 000 homeless
people living in l.a county
good luck with that we'll get to more of
this in just one second first
let us talk about the fact the holidays
are coming up and right now they're
telling you you shouldn't be traveling
anywhere
well given those facts the reality is
you're gonna be using the mail
an awful lot but you don't want to head
down to the post office because that
defeats the purpose instead you should
be heading over to stamps.com
on your computer with stamps.com
anything you can do
at the post office you can do with just
a few clicks plus stamps.com saves you
money with deep discounts you can't even
get at the post office here at daily
wire we've been using stamps.com since
2017 we don't waste our time or our
money
stamps.com brings the services of the us
postal service and ups
right to your computer stamps.com is a
must-have for any business whether
you're a small office sending out
invoices or an online seller fulfilling
orders during this record-setting
holiday season or even a giant warehouse
sending thousands of packages a day
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
simply use your computer to friends of
prince official u.s postage
247 for any letter any package any class
of mail anywhere you want to send it and
you get huge discounts like five cents
off every first class stamp up to 40
off priority mail up to 62 off ups
shipping rates don't spend a minute of
your holiday season at the post office
this year go to stamps.com and save time
and save money the way we have at the
shapiro household and here at the daily
wire there is no risk with my promo code
shapiro get a special offer
it includes a four-week trial plus free
postage and digital skill no long-term
commitments
or contracts just go to stamps.com click
on the microphone at the top of the
homepage
type in shapiro that is stamps.com enter
code shapiro
okay so meanwhile joe biden
is out there telling people that they
should stop complaining about the
coveted restrictions
uh he actually told people to talk to
veterans of world war one which is kind
of difficult because they're all dead
it's now 20 20. anyway here is uh here's
joe biden
well i have this mask on it's less about
me
being safe it's about me making sure
that you're safe
it's a patriotic thing to do it really
is
you know i hear all this about well it's
a great sacrifice of my freedom
well tell that to all the people who
went to
world war one and gave their lives in
world war ii
and the korean war and tell me come on
you're helping other people not you
it's other people other people okay now
listen
i've been all along in favor of masking
in places where you're in close contact
with other people but
this old daughtering idiot telling you
that you have to talk to veterans of
world war one so you feel more patriotic
and wear a mask this is not about mask
scoring at this point okay we have
spikes everywhere
in the country people are wearing masks
and they are still getting it because as
it turns out
very few people are wearing the most
effective type of masks many of the
people who are wearing
masks are not doing so in proper medical
fashion you actually require ppe
training in order to properly wear a
mask
you can you can bring down the risk but
when you have community spread that is
this prevalent
that community spread is unlikely to
stop simply because you have universal
masking orders in place
universal masking has been a thing in la
and they just shut down the entire city
again again it was two weeks to stop the
spread in march i remember it was the
week after my kid was born
and they've been locked down basically
ever since and so the
this there was this bizarre idiotic
notion that there was some sort of
silver bullet to the pandemic and it was
joe biden going on tv
and telling people to wear masks or
democratic mayors of major cities
telling people they should stay home and
that was going to solve this thing that
was never going to solve this thing
there's only one thing that's going to
solve this thing and that is the vaccine
or it's going to move through enough of
the population that a certain level of
herd immunity is formed the problem with
immunity of course is that you can't
actually control who is going to get
this thing
and who is not going to get this thing
which is why shielding the most
vulnerable should have always been
the top priority but i'll tell you
something else the people who are
promoting these orders
they know that these orders are not
keepable because they've not been
obeying these orders themselves
there's one constant pattern throughout
this pandemic and that is the rules are
for the little people
the rules are for people like you and
like me they are not for the specials
and not all animals are created equal
some animals are more equal than others
and political animals are more equal
than you
so for example london breed is the mayor
of san francisco determined to drive her
city directly into the ground by making
sure that
low-level crimes are never ever enforced
she suggested
that they may need more restrictive
action in san francisco
here was mayor breed it's not good
cases are spiking hospitalizations are
increasing quickly
our infection rate is higher than it was
at a point during the summer
our dangerous winter has arrived
the truth is we are going to have to
take more restrictive action
and it pains me to say that everything
we are asking you to do over the coming
weeks and months is about that
saving lives okay that's nice
so why were you at the french laundry
last month seriously london breed
was dining at the upscale french i don't
know what's up with the french laundry
is it like just a hidey hole for the
rich and fam i guess it is it's 400
bucks a plate or something
i've heard from people who've been there
that it's quite good but i'm just
wondering why every politician in
california
feels the necessity to violate their own
coveted regulations by going to the
french laundry
best thing that i saw in the last week
was a restaurant in l.a like a taco shop
they just put out a big sign on the
front of it because they've been told
they have to shut down they put out a
big sign
on the front of it that said french
laundry outdoor patio to make fun of the
fact that so many of these
rep these democratic politicians have
been violating their own rules
london breed just last month head on
over to the french laundry restaurant in
napa county
that came just after she joined seven
others on november 7th to celebrate the
60th birthday of socialite
goret lo liu a spokesman for the mayor
told the san francisco chronicle
their dining area was in a partially
enclosed room with a ceiling and a
chandelier
just like gavin newsom's widely
criticized birthday dinner at the
restaurant
one day earlier one day earlier okay so
remember
it's not just london breed right it's
gavin newsom here's a flashback
to gavin newsom talking about how he was
so sad
apologizing for the fact that he went to
an indoor dining restaurant while
telling everybody else to stay home
you can quibble about the guidelines et
cetera et cetera but the spirit
of what i'm preaching all the time was
contradicted and i got to own that
and so i want to apologize to you
because i need to preach
and practice not just preach and not
practice and i've done my best to do
that
we're all human we all fall short
sometimes
uh we've been out i think for three
times since
in fact i know it's been three times
because i remember all of
those dinners very very vividly oh so he
said i love that he sort of just slides
right in there by the way
i did this a couple more times also okay
it's not just democratic politicians in
california however
it is also democratic politicians in
texas so this is a great story
the mayor of austin his name is steve
adler
yesterday or the day before he decided
that he was going to tell everybody
that they ought to stay home don't
travel stay home stay home if you can
here was steve adler telling austin
residents to stay home
in a facebook video just in the last
couple of weeks
the thrust of the most important
messages trying to get out to the
community right now
is that our numbers are increasing and
everybody has to be aware of that
and then we need to you know stay home
if you can
do everything you can to try to keep the
numbers down
this is not the time to to relax we're
going to be looking really closely
uh and and i'm going to add a new
message we have
trying to do contact tracing to see if
we may have to close things down if
we're not careful
okay uh that looks like kind of a nice
background there steve adler mayor of
austin
where would you be steve adler mayor of
austin oh
well he was in cabo san lucas in mexico
when he said this
because literally what happened is that
well health officials were warning of an
impending kovitz bike
austin mayor adler hosted an outdoor
wedding and reception with 20 guests for
his daughter at a trendy hotel
near downtown the next morning adler and
seven other weathering attendees boarded
a private jet
for cabo or the vacation for a week at a
family time share
and then from the family timeshare in
cabo after having gone
to a pretty large event he decided to
lecture everybody in austin about how
they needed to stay home
because the rules only apply to the
little people don't you understand
the rules only apply to the little
people we'll get to more of the rules
only applying to the little i mean you
wonder why we don't trust public
officials
because it feels like you guys want to
lock everybody down except yourselves
you trust yourselves to be reasonable
and again
i'm trusting that steve adler isn't
making bad decisions for himself and his
family
i'm trusting that gavin newsom isn't
making bad decisions i mean he's a 52
year old man i believe
who's in good health with no preexisting
conditions i trust that mayor breed
is in decent health and is taking care
of herself because you know what i trust
people to make good decisions for
themselves this is not me
that you can't have local businesses
that say you're not allowed to come in
here without a mess that's fine you're a
local business you can do whatever you
want but this idea that eric garcetti is
going to lock everybody in their house
while
allowing riots to overrun his city in
the middle of the summer
and giant protests to run down melrose
avenue smashing
windows and burning police cars uh no i
mean the answer is no no one's going to
take you seriously nor should they take
you seriously because you are not taking
this stuff seriously
right the the bizarre sort of elitism
of our political class who believe that
they are brilliant enough
to handle their own health but you are
not brilliant enough to handle your own
health
it's it's pretty irritating and i think
most americans are and should be
irritated with it
we'll get some more of this in just one
second first let us talk about a
fantastic gift you can do for somebody
this christmas or this hanukkah i'm
talking about something really easy and
something really fast and something
really cool i'm talking about
myphoto.com
so very often if you want to get
somebody a photo you have to go to
printers you have to print it or you
have to
go to some sort of framing shop or
something like that to come back and
look all that great
takes time it's really time intensive
instead why not try my photos so here's
myphoto.com here's what they do you take
them you have the photos on your phone
right you just go to myphoto.com you
upload the photo
from your phone to myphoto.com and they
send you back
an email with all of the various options
for the kind of objects you can put the
picture on we were talking about
metal glass wood and more it takes two
minutes to do and then you get it in
five days
and it comes in a beautiful gift box
with the holidays coming up i barely
need to do anything to make something so
personal
and special these guys have made
millions of customers memories come to
life forever you have to try it it's
really fun it's really easy
and it's not expensive either we have a
couple of these around our house we're
gonna get more
because we have beautiful pictures of
our little baby and it makes it so easy
right i mean just take my phone
send the photo into my photo boom five
days later arriving in the mail is this
beautiful photo
for us we like the acrylic arrangement
it's really really beautiful the light
shines through it go to myphoto.com
right now
use the code bend25 get 25 off you'll
see how easy and fun it is it can be
addictive it is easy it is fast anybody
can do it go check them out right now
myphoto.com plus i know the owners of
the company really good solid family
people go check them out right now
myphoto.com use the code ben25 get 25
percent off makes a fantastic holiday
gift especially when we can't all
be together okay so it turns out that it
is not just
the austin mayor either it is the la
county supervisor sheila cool
so you'll remember just a couple of days
ago it was reported that the la county
board of supervisors had banned outdoor
dining that did not stop sheila cool
on tuesday from attending a fancy
italian restaurant in santa monica
outdoors
she was at ilforno trattoria in santa
monica i know it's up with california
maybe because they're so strict and so
crazy and it's a one-party state but
apparently every single politician in
california will do this all of them
apparently sheila kuel's spokesperson
said she did dine alfresco at el forno
on the very last day it was permissible
she loves ilforno has been saddened to
see it like so many restaurants
suffer from a decline in revenue she ate
there taking appropriate precautions and
sadly will not dine there again
until our public health orders permit oh
well
how about san jose's mayor is he doing
any better no
of course not so now it turns out that
san jose mayor
sam licardo appears to have broken
health protocols in celebrating
thanksgiving with family members outside
of his own household unit
ah there's a shocker the nbc bay area
investigative unit has learned that le
cardo celebrated with his elderly
parents
at their saratoga home with an unknown
number of other guests while the mayor's
staff did confirm the dinner took place
they haven't disclosed how many other
people attended how many different
households were present and whether any
of those in attendance wore masks while
not eating
this is a private event not public said
jim reed lucario's chief of staff we're
going to redraw the line between what is
personal and what is public because that
line has become blurred
weird because gavin newsom and eric
garcetti and democrats all over the
state of california
have been suggesting that they will
drive up to your house and ticket you if
you are outside of your home
with somebody else's family but
apparently if you're the mayor of san
jose
it's fine you can be there kova doesn't
affect you you're a democrat
demo i mean it's really it's amazing
like you can be there with your elderly
parents
and a bunch of other strangers in a room
not wearing masks while eating and it's
totally fine but all restaurants in the
state of california
should be shut down reed said that
locato and other guests practice social
distancing while gathering and eating
outside well if that's true then why
can't everybody do that
and the answer is that those other
people are not special like sam licardo
is special
remember sam licardo is mayor of san
jose he tweeted
like while this was happening like
during thanksgiving weekend cases are
spiking in part because we're letting
our guard and masks down with family and
friends
let's cancel the big gatherings this
year and focus on keeping each other
safe
well again doesn't apply to him and by
the way you think i'm done here i'm not
done here there's plenty more where this
came from gang
the denver mayor mayor hancock he
apparently
made national headlines why because
while telling everybody else that they
should stay home
he hopped on an airplane to mississippi
to visit his wife and youngest daughter
for thanksgiving after telling everybody
to refrain from traveling
he apologized on mondays at first i want
to say my decision was unwise and
hypocritical
a mistake that i want to deeply
apologize for my mayor my job as mayor
has not only helped come up with safe
practices for the entire city it's also
to set an example
on that measure i failed and they said
to try and make amends i traveled back
to denver as soon as i could
i will as i'd already planned to go into
self-quarantine until i'm confident
through testing i'm not infected but i
realize none of this is really good
enough
i'm hoping the people of denver can
forgive me well again he's a special
he shouldn't have to apologize he's a
special person because they're all
special people don't you understand if
you are a democrat you are a special
and the rules do not apply to you if you
you're protesting for black lives matter
and spitting all over other people
kova didn't apply to you because it's a
woke virus if you're a democratic
elected official it doesn't apply to you
if however your last name is trump then
you are actually the creator of the
virus
you are the person who wants the virus
to spread if you're a governor around
the sanderson florida you are to blame
for the virus to spread does it matter
that right now the per capita rates in
florida are way below
most other states at the top of that
chart okay but
doesn't matter rhonda census is bad
trump is bad christina is bad
all the democrats who put in place these
rules and then ignore them those are
good those are good democrats
and it's all of them it's all of them
remember
andrew cuomo the greatest governor in
all the land governor of new york
captain american crisis leadership man
coveted 19 shipped the elderly people
back in the nursing homes with kovid
that guy told everybody to stay home for
thanksgiving and then he just casually
announced on the radio
that his mother who's 89 was coming for
thanksgiving along with his daughters
that is the intergenerational kind of
gathering that we've been told
not to pursue during thanksgiving here's
andrew cuomo
the story is my mom is going to come up
and two of my girls is the current
plan but the plans change
um but that's my plan and then it was
whoopsie doodle right then it was whoops
you know what i my plan is
we've changed our plans we're not doing
that anymore you'll remember mayor lori
lightfoot
from chicago the the woman who suggested
after the election that science was back
science was back
remember that lori lightfoot went out to
get her hair done in the middle of the
pandemic
and then she was asked about it and
she's like you know it's an essential
service that i get a haircut because i'm
special
i mean first of all whoever does her
hair doesn't do a great job but beyond
that i'm pretty sure that's not an
essential service
here was mayor lori lightfoot defending
her own violation of her quarantine
rules
i'm the public face of this city i'm on
national media and i'm out in the public
eye
and you know i'm i'm i'm a person who
i take my personal hygiene very
seriously as i said i
felt like i needed to have a haircut i'm
not able to do that myself and so
i got a haircut first of all she has a
black and decker cordless saw she could
do that haircut
okay but not that i'm a stylist
but that that is not like uh jennifer
aniston hair circa 1997. okay not a lot
of fancy stuff going on with that hair
but that was an essential service cause
she's special bill de blasio was so
special he could go to the gym
like to the ymca just hours ahead of the
new york corona virus shutdown
early on the rules only apply to people
who are not
who are not these people the specials
don't have to follow the rules
and then people wonder why aren't you
following the rules because you know
what
none of these people are better than i
am and they certainly ain't smarter than
i am so guess what
i'm going to follow reason i'm going to
follow logic i'm going to take
precautions i should be taking
and i trust other americans to do the
same because that's the nature of
freedom
not that you get to run around spitting
in everybody's face but that you get to
exercise your own reason
so long as you are not threatening
others end of story
and we'll get to more of this in just
one second because the media coverage on
this stuff is just egregious as always
as always
we'll get some more of that in a second
first let's talk about a threat to your
asset base so
you have a lot of assets in your house
right you got some jewelry you got your
cars but your most expensive asset the
asset that probably
makes up a huge portion of your actual
household asset is your house
right your house is a giant asset
nobody's going to back up a truck to
your house and like drive it away or
something
but they can get the value that is
inherent in your home through home title
theft
so what is this well a cyber thief finds
your home title online forges your
signature on a quit claim deed stating
you sold your home to him then he takes
out loans against your home until your
equity is gone you won't know until the
collection calls pour in you're not
protected by insurance your bank or
common identity theft of programs
well home title lock will protect you
and in the unlikely event you become a
victim of title theft while remember
home title lock will spend up to a
quarter million dollars in legal fees to
help restore
your home's title in the first place so
head on over to hometitlelock.com right
now
register your address see if you're
already a victim then use code radio and
you get 30 free days of protection that
is code radio
at home title lock.com again go check
them out at home title lock.com and use
code radio
for 30 free days of protection to
protect your most valuable asset okay so
as always the media coverage on this
stuff is
absolutely egregious all you see is the
top line stats
and the number of deaths the number of
cases right then
will not tell you how many cases have
been diagnosed versus how many of
asymptomatics are walking around they
will not tell you the striation
in terms of the public health risk per
population and the answer is unless you
have a fairly significant underlying
condition
covet is not supremely deadly for you it
is
slightly more deadly than the flu if you
are healthy
but even then it depends on the age
striation if you're under the age of 20
and you don't have a significant
underlying condition even if you do have
a significant underlying condition
you're actually under the age of 20.
your chances of death are lower than
that of the flu
if you're between the ages essentially
of 20 and death and you don't have any
significant underlying condition
then this thing is not supremely deadly
the vast majority of people
who have died of this thing have a
significant underlying condition johns
hopkins university
today's study what they found is that of
all the people who have died of this
thing
well on medicare meaning everyone in the
country over the age of 65 which is
like the bulk of people who have died in
this country from this thing
a grand total this is as maybe a couple
weeks ago a grand total
of 2500 people over the age of 65 on
medicare died with no serious
preexisting condition
okay what does that mean it doesn't mean
you should willy-nilly go around and act
like the thing doesn't exist
and it means that you should assess your
own health risk but again i am fully
cognizant of the fact i think people can
be reasonable about their own health
and the health of people they love and
the health of their neighbors that's why
i haven't been
robustly anti-masking particularly when
you are in close quarters with other
people
but the mandatory lockdowns the idea
that democrats can simply lock you in
your home
and then they can go out to the french
laundry no the answer is no
it doesn't have to be this way people
can be reasonable i've talked about this
before
right so i've been in california where
it's full lockdown all the time crazy
towns people staring at you and yelling
at you
if you don't wear your mask even if
you're jogging 13 miles away from them
they'll
call you up on your phone just to chide
you if you're not wearing your mask
because they've got a satellite watching
you
and then you come over to florida and
florida is basically like
listen use your own rational use your
own
use your own rationality use reason and
you know what we are using reason
okay if i want to eat outdoors with my
family i will eat outdoors with my
family if i want to get together with
others and socially distance
i will do that i recently got together
with the rabbi of my synagogue
the rabbi of my synagogue happens to
have an underlying condition
we sat very far apart outside and we
talked and it was great
because guess what people have brains
this
this does go to liberal versus
conservative a lot of people have
wondered why is it that lockdown orders
in the united states have broken down
left versus right because actually what
you see all over the world
is that it has broken down in reverse in
some areas right as the left in israel
that is protesting against benjamin
netanyahu's lockdown orders netanyahu is
of the right
you've seen in great britain that boris
johnson has engaged in lockdown orders
and he's been hit by both people on his
right and people on his left
so why is it such a left-right issue in
the united states and the answer
is the reason it is a left-right issue
in the united states is that
many people on the right have basically
said listen the
basic function of liberty is that you
get to exercise
your freedom so long as you're not
harming anybody else and that means that
we trust you
to be smart enough to protect yourself
and to take measures to protect
people that you love and to protect your
neighbors like we're not going to go
around and allow you to just you know
infect people with covered willy-nilly
but we are also going to rely on human
beings to act
reasonably okay that is a basic
conservative
position okay then there's the left-wing
position which is we don't trust the
people to do anything
we can run your life better than you can
the rules don't apply to us because
we're smart but you're stupid and so we
are going to lock everything down and we
are going to dictate rules to you that
are completely onerous
non-sustainable and we're going to
enforce them with the power of law
that's why it's become a left-right
issue in the united states it didn't
have to be a left-right issue in the
united states
there was a happy medium the happy
medium tended to be more liberty
oriented
but the left has decided that liberty
itself is the challenge i can't tell you
the number of ridiculous thing pieces i
have seen over the past few months
from folks on the left saying it's the
american concept of liberty that is to
blame for all of this
well that's weird because um about
million half people have died worldwide
also if your big problem with the
pandemic is the american concept of
liberty let me suggest
that you are both not understanding how
this pandemic works and also that you
don't understand how liberty works
and what you really want more than
anything is just control and there is
this sort of paganistic aspect
to so much of how people are thinking
about covet 19.
the most obvious example of this i can
think of prince harry yesterday
he's a nut okay so he said in a recent
interview
for waterbear a streaming platform
dedicated to environmental documentaries
which is just i mean
riveting stuff can't wait to subscribe
to water bear
and watch a documentary about the salmon
swimming upstream that's gonna be some
stellar material
prince harry's lofty wish according to
the new york post is for every person to
be the quote raindrop that falls from
the sky
and relieves the parched ground
but he said at the end of the day
nature is our life source wow tell me
next that people need water to survive
and error to breathe yes this
this is true now this is my favorite
part here he goes he says
somebody said to me at the beginning of
the pandemic it's almost as though
mother nature has sent us to our rooms
for bad behavior
to really take a moment and think about
what we've done
um that is just paganistic crap
right there why don't you perform a
human sacrifice to mother nature there
harry
so mother nature apparently is mother
nature is sentient and
this is the part of these are the people
of science the people of science right
follow the science also
mother nature is angry at us right the
pandemic is angry at us
so presumably if we perform some sort of
propitiation
ritual then the gods will alleviate
our horrifying condition and all this
will go away
thanks prince harry really appreciate it
and the media treat it the exact same
way
they treat the exact same way so here's
an example
christine they're they're now doing to
christy know what they tried to do to
rhonda santa's very early on so
very early on the talk was ron desantis
killing millions in florida they had
this idiot
who was walking around wearing like a
death a death costume
on the beaches in jacksonville where by
the way i'm not aware there were any
diagnosed cases spread on the beaches in
jacksonville he was walking around like
a grim reaper costume telling people to
socially distance
he was a lawyer which says a lot from my
industry okay and um
ron desantis was of course the fond
height of death and we got headlines
from the atlantic about how brian kemp
in georgia
he was performing in experiments in
human sacrifice that's an actual
headline
in the atlantic george's experiment in
human sacrifice
didn't happen and meanwhile andrew cuomo
up north of new york was doing a
fantastic job
well now they are doing the same thing
to christy noam so christy noam is super
duper pooper scooper bad she's awful
awful awful
she's so awful she kills her own
grandmother according to the daily beast
now there's
only one problem christinom's
grandmother did not in fact die of covid
not only that christina in south dakota
has not prevented
people from protecting nursing homes the
entire premise of this piece however is
she doesn't care if her own grandmother
died of not covet
i'm going to get to this piece in in one
in a second because it does demonstrate
the full-scale
insane value system and judgments that
are brought upon people of the right by
people of the left in the media
who will meanwhile just sort of shut
yeah it's kind of bad that gavin newsom
went to the french laundry but at least
he's probably getting the right policies
guys
i mean sure stalin has his dasha and
it's really it's a really nice
shot like out in the woods it's really
it's really fantastic and sure everybody
else is super poor but it's the system
that matters and that system is bringing
equality
and justice we'll get to more of the
double standard
in just one second first let's talk
about a fantastic meaningful gift
okay so over the couch in our den we
have this beautiful portrait it's a
portrait of me
and my wife and two of our three kids we
need to update the portrait we're gonna
get a new portrait from paint
paintyourlife.com because we have a
beautiful squishy baby
we need to go to paintyourlife.com
here's what paint your life dot com does
you get a professional hand-painted
portrait created from any photo at a
truly affordable price
you can send any picture yourself your
kids family a cherished pet you can
combine photos into one painting so even
if people aren't together
they will just mash those up and turn it
into a beautiful portrait
with paint your life's compilation
portraits you can bring your family
members
together people who never had the chance
to meet or you can create a portrait of
the whole family without the need for
everybody to be there for a family photo
you can choose from a team of
world-class artists and work with them
until every detail is perfect
it's a quick and easy process and get a
hand painted portrait in about three
weeks
it's meaningful personal it can be
cherished forever it makes the perfect
holiday gift for somebody you love or
for yourself
just go check them out right now at
paintyourlife.com and they are offering
a special offer
as a limited time offer you get 20 off
your painting that is correct 20
off and free shipping to get the special
offer text my name ben to 64 000 that
has been
to 64 thousand again text ben to
sixty-four thousand
paint your life celebrate the moments
that matter most and get started right
now okay in just one second
we're gonna get to the media's coverage
of christina because it is fully crazy
first if you're not already a daily wire
member now is the time to join we've got
some incredible stuff right around the
corner
so for example starting this friday
december 4th the michael moles show is
going five days a week to my great
consternation and rage with more content
for our members to enjoy
or alternatively suffer through we are
also adding the entire prageru catalog
to dailywire.com by the end of the year
we've already uploaded all of prageru's
five-minute videos the candice owens
show from prageru
michael moles book club the rest of the
library is being added as we speak
and early next year candace is joining
the daily wire here in nashville
she'll be launching a brand new daily
wire show in front of a live
studio audience it's the first of its
kind show ever on the right it should be
awesome we are also
launching our first feature film it's a
legit feature film under dailywire's
upcoming
entertainment channel it's kinda awesome
we are building a new investigative
journalism team as well to replace that
legacy media cartel so
go outside the narrative come on over to
dailywire.com subscribe we are loud
opinionated we're having a good time and
we are taking down the legacy media we
need your help to do it head on over to
dailywear.com
subscribe also you have not ordered them
yet check out our daily wear christmas
ornaments yes
all of us were immortalized forever on
the daily wear christmas ornament
including me santa's most adorable
orthodox jewish elf
hey go check out those bizarre ornaments
by texting christmas to 83 400 and get
your tree decorated
with me i'm very handsome knowles he's
knowles jeremy boring very beardy matt
walsh also very beardy
and uh and an alien that looks like
andrew clavin text christmas to 83 400
to get your tree decorated now these
ornaments are going fast so get yours
right now you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
so as i'm mentioning the media have been
going hard after christy noam why
well because she is a very good governor
she's very effective she's very
charismatic and obviously she's a very
good-looking woman and this scares the
living hell
out of the democrats who see her as a
possible republican nominee or vice
presidential nominee
in four years if donald trump does not
emerge victorious maybe even if he does
in 2024 okay so here is the daily beast
take on christine
right she's in the new face of the
villainous crew before it was
it's all these republican governors
you've noticed have you noticed right
it's ron desantis or greg abbott
or perhaps brian kemp in georgia
meanwhile governor gavin newsom in
california who's doing a crappy job or
andrew cuomo who's doing
amazing amazing at their jobs okay so
christy noam is the new villainous of
the day
this is the worst story ever okay you
ready anti-mask gov's
grandmother died in nursing home ravaged
by kovid now if i just read you that
headline
wouldn't that sound like her her grandma
died of covid and then it's kind of her
fault
right isn't that the idea of the
headline especially because the
the sub headline is and yet chris gnome
continues to downplay the virus refuse a
mass mandate and ignore the terrible
price her state
is paying and i'm going to read the
story and as you'll see not a single
fact
in this story backs up the headline
contention it turns out grandma did not
die of covid
it turns out the nursing home in which
grandma lived was not infected due to
lack of a mass mandate it turns out they
took serious precautions in the state of
south dakota particularly with regard to
nursing homes
doesn't matter christina's bad and she's
bad and we're gonna rip on her because
grandma died that's how evil and
disgusting
many of our legacy media are and the
author of this garbage piece of guy
named michael daley
says on monday south dakota governor
christie noma buried her grandmother
who's among 13 to die over a two-week
period at a top-rated nursing home
swept by covet 19. the 98 year old
grandmother
eldest arnold is said by gnome's office
to have tested negative for the virus
though no cause of death was given so
why are we talking about
how she died of covid when she didn't
actually die of covid
the other 12 of the 13 deaths between
november 14th and 28th at the esteline
nursing home are described by the
administrator mike ward as
coveted related all but one ward told
the daily beast but one less is still a
dozen coveted deaths in a short period
in one small facility
the number makes clear the lunacy of
gnome's downplaying of the pandemic and
her continued refusal to impose a
statewide mass mandate okay so now you'd
say okay well it sounds like
if there'd been a mass mandate then
everything would have been fine
nope so gnome tweeted i've always taken
coven 19 very seriously
but south dakota trusted our citizens to
exercise their personal responsibility
to keep themselves
and their loved ones safe but the report
from estonia nursing homes in a town of
the same name made clear
south dakotans are anything but safe
ward confirmed that along with the
deaths all but two of the surviving 38
residents and at least 16 of the staff
had tested positive
the two most recent deaths were on
saturday helped raise the state-wide
daily total to 54 a record for south
dakota which has fewer than 1 million
people
none of this is to say that noam is it
all cold-blooded when the lives include
one of her own clan
she tweeted a moving tribute to arnold
on november 22nd we lost my grandma
today but she is finally where she has
wanted to be for quite some time
with jesus and grandpa and my dad and
ryan and so many loved ones i remember
when my dad died she said to me with
tears rolling down her cheeks children
should never die before their parents i
had never seen my grandma
die before gnome's father aldous
arnold's son was killed in a 1994
accident involving farm machinery
ryan arnold elders grandson and gnome's
cousin died in 2010 of surgical
complications
after donating part of his liver to his
brother
and she talked about her grandmother and
how wonderful she was if her gnome to
have mentioned
the does another dead would have raised
the specter of the virus that killed
them even if she was continuing to claim
she'd brought it under control by
invoking personal responsibility
rather than mandating a vital precaution
again mass mandates have been tried in
germany
boom spike italy spike uk spike france
spike
the idea that mass mandates are the
cure-all is idiocy it is not backed
by the evidence this is not to say you
should not wear a mask
you should be reasonable for the one
thousandth time this show and the one
millionth time since the pandemic began
but the the media have the silver bullet
and if you don't yell mass mandate from
the rooftops then apparently
you're responsible for every cove of
death that happens subsequently now
here's the best part
okay so they start off with the
assumption that her grandmother died of
coven then within the first two
paragraphs turns out grandma didn't die
of covet
then the next assumption is well she
must have blown it somehow with regard
to policy at the nursing home right
i mean after all the entire article is
predicated on her not caring about the
elderly in her own state
whoops here we go nobody could rightly
blame the nursing home itself
for failing to protect its residents as
best it could state and federal
inspectors had consistently given the
home their highest ratings
its record is unblemished by so much as
a serious single violation the family of
one of the dead nine-year-old
artist aplin described esteline to the
daily beast as excellent
and reported that the home took
extensive precautions against coven 19
long before anybody there tested
positive aplin's son-in-law david harold
said visitors were required to wear
masks and met with the residents in a
separate room partitioned by plexiglas
and plastic sheeting
visitors and residents were kept
separated but through the plastic harold
could see
that aplin was continuing to thrive
since moving into the home in june
then as best as ward can tell an
asymptomatic staffer brought the virus
into the facility from the outside
presumably having caught it in the realm
where masks are not required
and where gnome has allowed people to
gather in crowds as large as a quarter
million at a bike rally
okay so there's no evidence that the
person even got it at the bike rally
we have no idea where the person who got
it got it lots of people have been
getting it in new york
in california california's experiencing
a massive surge right now
okay and the idea is christinom is
somehow responsible for an asymptomatic
person
picking up the virus from community
spread and bringing it into a heavily
protected nursing home
that's the daily beast idea
i mean i'm sorry this is ridiculous it's
ridiculous on its face
but this is the way that the media are
going to cover this stuff you can break
whatever rules you damn well please if
you're a democrat
and if you are a republican then you
don't have to break any rules
in fact you can try to protect the
elderly in fact
they will they will blame you for
everything they'll blame me for a
grandmother who didn't die of covet in a
facility
that was basically wrapping people in
bubbles it's unbelievable
except it's all too believable of course
okay meanwhile
barack obama has come out and he says
that he's going to take the vaccine on
national tv
there are three ex-presidents actually
who have said that they are going to
take the vaccine on national
tv george w bush and bill clinton and
obama i believe have all said
they will take the vaccine on national
tv to demonstrate that it is safe that
is a good thing
a little late here president obama just
going to note that
kamala harris spent half of the
presidential race suggesting that she
would not take the vaccine if it was
approved by trump
here's barack obama now walking that
back i'm glad he's walking it back
by the way you want to hear more about
vaccines take a listen to noel's show
today he talks at length about the
vaccines here was uh here's
obama if you're a first responder
you should take that vaccine uh and i
promise you that when it's then
made for people who are less at risk
um i will be
taking it and and you know i may end up
taking it off
on tv or having it filmed just so that
people know
that uh you know uh
you know i i trust this science okay
well
i'm glad he does i wish that the
democrats would have said that back
during the summer when they were all
saying they would not right andrew cuomo
said that he would not actually approve
the vaccine for use in his state
absent a separate panel in new york
state evaluating the efficacy
and safety of the vaccine so uh thanks
for intervening on that
president obama now right right when
it's not all that useful i really very
much appreciate it like i'm glad he
was serious more seriously i am glad
that he is doing it
i will just note that he didn't say
anything about this prior to the
election when it was just donald trump
is bad
all day long okay speaking of the
election there's still some remaining
lawsuits that are outstanding
around the country as a good rundown by
joel over breitbart on this
so basically in arizona kelly ward who
leads the republican party of arizona is
challenging the election results
arguing the states that vote by mail
procedures are too lacks observers were
not able to verify the ballots being
counted
a judge allowed her access to about 100
ballots so she could check to see
whether in fact they were being
improperly tallied
and whether there were mis matches
between signatures
and uh and ballots and all of this in
georgia
the only live lawsuit there are a couple
live lawsuits one is from sydney powell
uh claiming bizarre things about
dominion that have yet to be approved
in any serious way as we'll see sydney
pal things are starting to collapse real
fast for cindy powell and for uh
and for lynn wood these are the two sort
of rogue lawyers who are out there
filing lawsuits
meanwhile in georgia there's a lawsuit
by the thomas more society arguing that
the center for technology and civic life
funded public safe elections operations
in predominantly democratic counties
violating state law and violating the
equal protection clause it's unlikely
that that is going to succeed in
michigan
powell has a suit so does the amistad
project of the thomas more society
they are suing over secretary of state
jocelyn benson's decision to send
absentee ballot forms
to every registered voter allegedly with
no authority and lacks standards again
you're gonna have to prove that this
resulted in fraud that was greater than
150 000 votes disparity between trump
and biden in the current count
in nevada the trump campaign has sued
six electors for joe biden on behalf of
six republican electors
alleging that nevada authorities
developed and implemented and
implemented
an election system that was highly
susceptible to fraud and abuse the
lawsuit claims
a flood of mail-in ballots officials in
clark county used electronic
verification
methods that are allegedly unreliable
but again this is more about the
possibility of voter fraud which
theoretically could change procedures
for the future rather than overturning
the results as they currently stand
there are a couple of cases that are
currently active in pennsylvania
one particularly comes with regard to
the expansion
of mail-in voting which is
unconstitutional it kind of looks like
facially
under the pennsylvania state
constitution the problem is the remedy
is
unlikely to be provided by the federal
judiciary because the pennsylvania
supreme court didn't provide it and it's
a state issue
and also the remedy even if there were
to be a remedy is unlikely to be tossing
out
all of the ballots that were mailed in
absentee in pennsylvania
this year in wisconsin there's a lawsuit
by the ema center for justice and
liberty it seeks to have the state's
mail-in ballots that were placed in
drop-off boxes invalidated
on the grounds that the boxes were
illegal there's also a lawsuit by the
wisconsin voters alliance targeting
the the ctcl which is that group that
has been
doing the get out the vote efforts
mainly in democratic areas none of this
is to suggest of course that voter fraud
and voter regularity aren't real i think
they're very real and we've seen proof
of some of it
in this election for sure president
trump gave a 46 minute speech last night
talking about how our system
is under siege he repeated a lot of the
claims that his people have been making
all over the country here with president
trump last night
we used to have what was called election
day
now we have election days weeks and
months
and lots of bad things happened during
this ridiculous period of time
especially when you have to prove almost
nothing
to exercise our greatest privilege the
right to vote
as president i have no higher duty than
to defend the laws and the constitution
of the united states
that is why i am determined to protect
our election system
which is now under coordinated assault
and siege
okay so uh part of this is is not
court cases again as i've been saying
from the beginning the legal process
is going to be basically through the
courts and sort of this last-ditch
effort being made by the trump campaign
to go in front of various state
legislatures in arizona
and michigan and house oversight
committees in michigan and
bring people forth to testify that they
have seen voter irregularities and or
voter fraud and some of these people are
pretty compelling
actually there was a an indian woman
last night
as in from india or of indian extraction
uh and uh she testified last night in
michigan she was actually pretty
compelling talking about
how there were people supervisors who
didn't understand how the voting
machines work and that when the
the machines jammed instead of taking
out the ballot and tossing it because it
had now been rendered
basically moot because you couldn't
actually see who voted uh they would
they would instead try to count the vote
and counter for joe biden
i mean there's been some evidence that's
been brought forth here and all of these
allegations should be investigated
probably the most bombshell allegation
was brought forth by a truck driver
named jesse morgan
uh he was testifying in front of the
michigan house oversight committee i
believe this was
uh actually actually he did this at a
presser in arlington virginia rather
and here he was claiming that as a truck
driver he was driving completed ballots
from new york to pennsylvania
and they were sort of put aside he was
suggesting that these were fraudulent
ballots that were eventually not counted
again it would be good to get some
support for these affidavits just
because you file an affidavit not in
court where it's not punishable does not
mean that what's filed in the affidavit
is right
there are lots of people who file
affidavits that are not in fact correct
i mean believe christine blasey ford
made allegations that were not
substantiated with regard to justice
kavanaugh but
should this be investigated absolutely
here is this here's the truck driver
i know i saw ballots with return
addresses filled out
thousands of them thousands
loaded onto my trailer in new york
and headed for pennsylvania at first
i didn't think it was a big deal but as
things became
weirder i got to thinking and wondered
why
i was driving complete ballots
from new york to pennsylvania so
apparently
uh he then left the trailer someplace
and then the ballots were not counted
something like that in any case
that's pretty serious allegation
obviously that should be investigated
i'll tell you however what is complete
idiocy
so yesterday lynnwood and sydney powell
you know the kraken lady
and and linwood both of whom apparently
have donated some significant money to
democrats in the past particularly lynn
wood as we'll discuss in a moment
they called on brian kemp to resign and
they urged republicans not to show up
and vote in the georgia senate elections
that's insane
okay whatever you think happened in this
election you're nuts if you sit out this
election because you're mad about what
happened
to trump in the georgia election 2020.
that's crazy so you're gonna allow
raphael warnock
to take that sentence and jon ossoff to
take that tennessee are you out of your
damned mind
are you crazy so your solution to
democrats
in your view stealing an election is to
allow them to take control of the senate
that is your solution
hey hero linwood and sydney pal
demonstrating full scale they're being
crazy people
until brian kemp comes out and orders a
special session
of the georgia legislature get us our
legislature
and tell everybody we want our
legislator to meet
and we want him to fix the mess that he
created
and then he can resign they've got to
demand
publicly repeatedly
consistently brian kemp
call a special session of the georgia
legislature
and if they do not do it if kelly
loffler and david perdue
do not do it they have not earned your
vote
don't you give it to them so
excuse me don't vote for the republicans
in the senate races
unless they call on brian kemp to call
the
legislature together to vote for trump
in the presidential
this is so your solution is to put
rafael warnock and john ossoff in the
senate it worth noting breitbart going
very hard
after lynn wood today pointing out here
that there is no record in georgia of
him ever voting for president trump in
2016 or 2020
in the republican primaries he did vote
in the 2020 and 2016 general elections
in georgia but there's no record
of him pulling a gop primary ballot
either of those years
also apparently he has given money to a
wide variety of democrats
apparently including apparently he uh he
worked with
he he worked with stacy evans a georgia
democrat gubernatorial candidate in 2017
he gave her nearly 13 000
evans would go on to lose to uh to
stacey abrams in that gubernatorial
primary
wood then donated another 2 500 bucks to
evans in november 2015.
2300 more in march 2010 2400 more in may
and in december 2009 another 100 bucks
he also gave money to
senator jason carter a democratic
candidate for governor of georgia in
2014.
he's donated to basically a bunch of
democrats lynnwood and now he's calling
shocker of shockers
he's now calling for everybody to not
vote for the republicans
genius move genius move by the way you
know who disagrees with this president
trump trump
said we have to work hard for senator
perdue and senator lefler and so
president trump tweeted
we'll be going to georgia for a big
trump rally in support of our two great
republican senators david and kelly
they're fantastic people who love their
country and love their state we must
work hard
and be sure they win that of course is
exactly correct
so whatever you think happened in this
election cycle don't be an idiot and sit
out an election
where you can keep an insane socialist
anti-american and i say anti-american
advisedly
because raphael warnock says that
america is steeped in racism he says
that america
is is inherently racist he he has
praised
jeremiah wright he is he he did youth
events for for a castro when he came to
his youth church or something
back in the 90s you want that guy
sitting in the senate or john ossoff
the offspring of extraordinarily rich
people who bought him a house in
washington dc and now walks around
parroting bernie sanders you want that
in the senate because you're mad about
what happened in georgia
that's about the dumbest thing you could
do okay meanwhile
the media continue to fluff joe biden
so jimmy kimmel doing his best to fluff
joe biden
he says you know what it's gonna be such
a boring four years guys it's gonna be
so boring this is the media's line when
a democrat is in office there's nothing
to cover and nothing to laugh about
we can't even make jokes and chris rock
once said that you literally could not
make jokes about barack obama because of
his god-like veneer there was just no
way to make jokes about him he was
inherently unfunny
and now we've got jimmy kimmel saying
that joe biden who is a
doddering old fool who cannot string
together a full paragraph
who broke his foot playing with his dogs
like a week ago that guy's not funny
it's just going to be a boring four
years guys says jimmy kimmel
weird because i noticed that you weren't
very bored the last four years
yeah maybe that's trump and maybe that
ain't i'm gonna go with it here's jimmy
kimmel
our president-elect was out and about
today showing off his brand new
orthopedic boot
mr president how does your foot feel
thanks boniva it's going to be a very
boring four years
yeah and then there's your media asking
tough questions like how does your foot
feel
joe biden solid stuff how do you think
his foot feels wearing a boot
yeah it feels fantastic bob everything's
great
solid stuff right there meanwhile
politico honing in on the things that
matter with regard to joe biden's picks
so i gotta say the left is so racist
mutts is so unbelievably racist
they see other people simply in terms of
their essentialist racist
characteristics it's un
it's incredible it's incredible okay so
there's an article in politico it's
called lawmakers to biden
step it up on cabinet diversity the next
administration
will feature a number of historic firsts
but lawmakers and advocates of color are
pushing
for more this is a reported piece that
took three reporters from politico to
put together
megan casella laura baron lopez and
alice miranda olsteen
a very diverse group because they're all
women as the media would put it here's
what they say quote
the faces of the economic team of
president-elect joe biden unveiled
publicly tuesday included
an african-american woman a man born in
nigeria an indian american woman
and just one white man okay so let me
just note
right off the top that that's a horrible
way to describe human beings
is it not right you see a group of
supposedly well-qualified candidates and
you don't describe them as
you know a former partner at some big
firm or former government official
or what they have done in their life you
describe them simply by their racial
characteristics
you know things that they have had since
they were born it's like a benetton ad
it's ridiculous okay the faces of the
economic team
included a black woman a man born in
nigeria an indian american woman and
just one
white man i mean so so basically we are
now just
picking faces from a catalog
remember that time that mitt romney was
ripped up and down for saying that he
had binders full of women because he
wanted women to fill cabinet positions
and the left was like that's terrible
how could he do that well now
politico is literally just running down
joe biden's picks
by by noting their races and their sexes
and presumably their sexual orientations
and i love this the response from asian
american black and latino democrats it's
not enough who thinks like this
seriously who thinks like this
i find this stuff so irritating as a jew
which is indeed a minority and in fact
the most victimized minority in the
united states if you take hate crimes
per capita
as a jew it has never once occurred to
me that when someone forms
a cabinet or a financial team or a
corporate team
that it is imperative that you have to
put a certain number of jews
on the team it's a ridiculous contention
why would you
what the hell does that have to do with
anything is it the genetics
of having a jewish mother that matter
here or is it qualifications like
what are you talking about right here
but according to politico they want more
representation particularly in the
cabinet
and after representative jim clyburn the
most senior black member of congress and
a key biden ally spoke out last week
about the need for more diversity in
biden's burgeoning administration
more black latino and asian-american
lawmakers are joining the chorus
texas representative vincent gonzalez he
said we're very very concerned as a
community as a latino community
he called last week for at least five
latinos to be appointed to cabinet level
positions
it doesn't matter which ones they are
presumably just as long as they are
latino
which is crazy is there such a thing as
like a latino interest
seriously like just there's a latino
perspective on the world there's a black
person
you know who agrees with this racist
like actual
honest-to-god neo-nazis and all white
racists believe this
okay and and apparently the democratic
party this is mainstream
asian american and pacific islander
advocates and officials are warning the
biden administration and writing it will
be quote
deeply disappointing if several
asian-american pacific islanders are not
nominated to cabinet positions
they're growing increasingly convinced
the president's elect will not match
barack obama's total
of three asian americans in his first
cabinets meanwhile the cbc the
congressional black caucus is urging
biden to choose a black defense
secretary
and up the number of african-americans
leading departments overall
i'm sorry this is the stupidest most
racist crap ever
ever it is so stupid and so racist and
the fact that everybody is just like oh
this is you know that's
it's important guys it's really
important the skin color of the people
you are selecting
now you know what seems more important
to me the character of the people being
selected by joe biden
so for example politico also reported
and this seems like this should get more
coverage
alex thompson and theodora meyer
reporting for politico
biden top economic advisor facing
accusations of mismanagement and verbal
abuse
but she's a woman so i guess it's okay
right is that that's the way that works
apparently
a former colleague of heather bushy a
top economic advisor to president
electro biden is publicly airing prior
concerns
that bushi mismanaged the think tank she
runs and verbally abused her and other
subordinates saying she wants to prevent
future white house employees from
enduring a similar experience
claudia sam former director of
macroeconomic policy at the washington
center for equitable growth
bushi's think tank published an account
of her and other former employees
experience
working with bushi on her personal
website tuesday night she wrote that
after her experience
i learned that heather's abusive
behavior was a pattern
former subordinates and employees have
alleged that bushi was quote
phenomenally incompetent as a manager
and had frequent episodes of yelling and
swearing the complaints were serious
enough the think tank where she worked
hired a management coach to work with
her
to improve her management style around
2015.
so good times good time but the
important thing is she's a woman
i mean that's really what we should
focus in on because it's the
diversity that matters right here that
that is
serious diversity that matters we need a
woman even if she is
abusive to people so really really good
stuff
okay meanwhile war is breaking out
inside the democratic party over the
direction of the democratic party
it was initiated by barack obama who
oddly enough
was not actually cutting against the
progressives see the real debate inside
the democratic party
is truly not over the future of the
direction of policy
it isn't i know there are some democrats
who believe that it is like joe manchin
i think believes that it is i think joe
manchin actually disagrees
with many of the policy prescriptions of
the alexander ocasio-cortez and the
rashida liebs
and the ilhan omars and such by the way
ilhan omar tweeted out yesterday
that we should cancel all rents and
mortgage payments which is pretty much
the stupidest thing ever she then
tweeted out an article pointing out how
stupid it was
because she didn't even read the article
the bottom of the article said this
would be a bad idea because
presumably thousands of people would
lose their jobs if you just cancel rents
and cancel mortgage payments
banks eat the loss have to not give as
many loans
and people who are landlords simply stop
developing further properties and so
rents actually go up which of course is
of course true
okay but the the debate inside the
democratic party
is very rarely between sort of
honest-to-god moderates
you know people like abigail spanberger
in virginia or conor lamb in
pennsylvania
it's it's it's usually not that usually
and this is the the
peculiar self-obsession of many of the
democrats it's about
how we approach the issue it's not that
we're wrong it's that the american
people are too stupid
so barack obama being raped over the
coals because
progressives are mad that he said that
defund the police is a bad slogan
now defund the police happens to be an
unbelievably crappy slogan it also
happens to be a terrible policy
police departments need more money right
now police departments
should not be defunded right now we're
seeing skyrocketing
murder rates in major cities across the
united states
we are seeing massive increases in
carjackings in minneapolis
according to hot air carjackings are up
over the past two months minneapolis
police have logged more than 125
carjackings in the city
a troubling surge authorities had
largely linked to a small group of
marauding teens but an increasing number
of adults have been arrested
in recent weeks for the same crime
according to the minneapolis star
tribune within one hour period saturday
morning police reported three separate
carjackings
in southeast minneapolis including one
where an elderly woman was struck on the
head
such attacks are up 537 percent this
month when compared with last
november okay 537 i i wonder how this
could have happened
could it be because the city council has
voted to basically defund the police
it's a bad policy but according barack
obama it's not that it's a bad policy
it's that it's phrased badly
because you see according to barack
obama every single stupid thing he
thinks
is actually a wonderful thing he thinks
it's just you are too stupid to
understand him
okay but the left is also too stupid to
understand him so instead of them being
like you know maybe barack's right maybe
we could sell
this garbage policy if we changed our
verbage instead of like no we want to
sell garbage policy and garbage verbiage
the real debate in the democratic party
ain't over the ends it is only over the
means
so here's barack obama and people on the
right who are falling for this saying oh
well you know obama's moderate he's
against defunding the police no he's not
he's in favor of defunding the police he
just doesn't want to call it defunding
the police
which was obama's ploy always was to
guide
guys his radicalism in the language of
of moderate
politics which he's not a moderate okay
but here's barack obama saying defund
the police is a bad slogan
and then of course he gets clubbed about
the ears by the squad
if you believe as as i do that we should
be able to reform the criminal justice
system
so that it's not biased and treats
everybody
fairly i guess you can use a snappy
slogan like
defund the police but you know you've
lost a big audience the minute you say
it which makes it a lot less likely that
you're actually going to get the changes
you want done
the key is deciding do you want to
actually get something done
or do you want to feel good among the
people you already agree with right so
the very end that's the part you're
saying right you want to get something
done
or do you want to feel good and the
progressive left they're like
we want to feel good that's their answer
and the the best exchange of the of the
last week was joe manchin
he said defend the police with a stupid
idea and aoc was like
she tweeted out a picture of herself
like glaring at him
during the state of the union address
last year and he
and he said something in an interview
like i saw that she was glaring daggers
at me
and she put that picture out but
honestly i don't know what she does
other than tweet and do instagram videos
and aoc was like that's not true i do
hard legislative work and then the next
day she put out a bunch of t-shirts for
58 dollars on her website
not joking that's a serious thing that
happened but the progressives are angry
angry with obama and this is the nature
of the dumbest po
our politics is so as always
unbelievably unbelievably stupid so you
have idiots on the right who are like
barack obama's moderate he said don't
defund the police
that's not what he said he said defund
the police just call it something else
and then you have the idiots on the
progressive left and they're like
he said don't defund the police and we
want to say defund the police
so you ended up with ilhan omar genius
ilhan omar
tweeting out we lose people in the hands
of police it's not a slogan but a policy
demand
and censoring the demand for equitable
investments in budgets for communities
across the country
gets us progress and safety um
it's not a slo it's a policy demand to
defund the police and then she proceeds
to explain it without using the words to
defund the police
we lose people in the hands of police
she is from minneapolis
the carjackings are 537 percent year on
year
we lose people in the hands of police
other members of the squad were
similarly
mad rashida talib again it's the answer
the anti-semitic geniuses of the squad
she tweeted
rosa parks was vilified an attack for
her civil disobedience
my favorite thing about the squad and
obama really it's all the same when it
comes to the arrogance
right they are all transformational
figures in their own mind so here is
rashida talib comparing herself to rosa
parks rosa parks was vilified and
attacked for her civil disobedience
she was targeted it's hard seeing the
same people who uplift her courage
attack the movement for black lives that
want us to prioritize health
funding of schools and ending poverty
rather than racist police
systems ayanna presley of massachusetts
she tweeted the murders of generations
of unarmed black folks by police have
been horrific
lives are at stake daily so i'm out of
patience with critiques of the language
of activists whatever a grieving family
says is their
truth and i'll never stop fighting for
their justice and healing and then you
have corey bush of missouri
right a new adjunct member of the squad
at some point she will earn her senior
assistant
her senior uh associate membership she
says with all due respect mr president
let's talk about losing people we lost
michael brown you didn't lose michael
brown michael brown attacked a police
officer and and tried to shoot him
with his own gun in his car we lost
brianna taylor we're losing our loved
ones to police violence it's not a
slogan
it's a mandate for keeping our people
alive defund the police
i again i love the fact that the
progressives are so stupid that they are
like
barack obama he must oppose defending
the police if he doesn't want us to use
the slogan
he literally said he likes defunding the
police he just wants you not to use the
slogan
and for people on the right i've been
seeing it all over the place people on
the right
who want to fall for the trap that
barack obama is actually a moderate
that barack obama is actually a unifying
force
he is not he is just trying to hide the
ball at least corey bush and ayanna
presley and all these jokers at least
these idiots are actually saying what
they think out loud obama's like
say it quietly guys say it quietly
they're like we don't want to say it
quietly
you think obama wants to stop the squad
no he doesn't want to stop the squad
here is obama in that same interview
saying that he wants aoc to be given
more time at the democratic national
convention
one thing i will say about the
democratic party promoting young people
is really important we stick so long
with
the same old folks and don't make room
for
new voices you know democratic national
convention i thought was really
successful considering the pandemic but
you know the fact that an aoc only got
what three minutes or five minutes
good evening bienvenidos and thank you
when you know she speaks to a broad
section of young people who
are interested in what she has to say
even if they don't agree with everything
she says
new blood's always good okay yeah so
this guy yeah he's the one who's gonna
put a lid on the radicalism inside the
democratic party
so here's the deal maybe joe biden
represents sort of the old guard of the
democratic party maybe he's more like
joe manchin he actually opposes some of
these policy prescriptions
or maybe he doesn't but the bottom line
is that the momentum is not with him
it is with the squad it is with the
defund the police crowd they can try to
paper it over with these niceties
but that papering is not going to last
very long it ain't going to last long
at all alrighty we'll be back here later
today with two additional hours of
content otherwise we'll see you here
tomorrow i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
borin
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are nick sheehan and
rebecca doyle
the show is edited by adam scievent
audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is by nico
geneva the ben shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
president trump vows to run again if he
loses just 12 votes separate
congressional candidates
in new york and wales is getting ready
to institute a
vaccine passport check it out on the
michael knowles show